olá pessoal aqui quem fala é o da área
que sejam muito bem vindos a mais um
vídeo e não só espírito não é que vai
tocar e quando se o mesmo infelizmente
bordo foi atacado por cães selvagens
dentro da minha própria casa
foi terrível mesmo quase morreu eu vou
deixar aqui algumas fotos para vocês
verem que ficou assim neste estado mas
já vamos estar mais fortes já vão
mostrar como ela está atualmente mais
gente disse eu quero muito participar de
um desfile pessoal é muito importante
mesmo não só por eu ter visualizações
porque sim eu quero ter muita
visualização que inspire porque eu quero
chegar a muitas pessoas ao máximo de
pessoas possível com este vídeo porque
para além de ser um vídeo explicar a
história do que aconteceu eu quero que o
espírito de um vídeo de alerta e eu
quero que muitas pessoas pensam que eu
vou dizer porque é um assunto realmente
importante eu acho que falta um pouco de
consciência das pessoas então partilhem
ao máximo esse pessoal manda pro axapi
manuel vaz de caminha de maneira insta
grama nem para toda a gente é porque
tudo está aqui tudo que tem acontecido
aqui tem origem nos problemas dos
problemas precisam ser falados precisam
ser resolvidos e precisam ser expostos
às pessoas e quanto mais pessoas a
ajudar a resolver o problema claro que o
mais rápido faz funcionar então partilha
ao máximo pessoal sério deixem lá e
comentário faça o que vocês quiserem mas
partilham um vídeo km intenção inicial
também não era utilizar este vírus se eu
não usar o vídeo o youtube vai entender
que isso não é um vídeo bom para
partilhar portanto também não vai
partilhar
então ele vai ter um sistema a ser
utilizado sim mas apenas por uma questão
de partida enfim vamos lá antes de
descontar o ataque em si como aconteceu
como os cães entraram aqui como atacaram
o bobcats o iraque um pouco e junte se
de tudo o que a acontecer aqui em sintra
e bom pra quem não sabe quem sinta mais
precisamente na quinta da glória que é
um estudo está a acontecer e erdogan
também e eu já estou aqui há cerca de
108 meses eo não se lhe estava acontecer
eu não sabia que existiam estes cães que
tentavam atacar pessoas e animais não
sabe de tudo nem sequer vinha pra cá e
este é outra das coisas que eu quero
falar mais à frente e que inspire
portanto não percam pessoal vez um vídeo
até o fim está em causa aqui também
estaria nesta casa e eu estava vivendo
aqui porque estou a pensar seriamente em
seguir não sinto segura onde tu viver
atualmente pois destaque então muito
menos mas nós vamos falar isso aqui é só
para você ter uma noção do que está a
acontecer vamos ter aqui uma matéria que
saiu no correio da manhã e ao final três
grupos kanji princípio em sintra
mas eles ainda não foram capturados por
falta de capacidade da autarquia são
transmitidas de identificadas pela
câmara municipal de sintra estão
assustados porque elas passa uma das
manilhas com cerca de dez cães
até com algumas pessoas na zona da
quinta da glória segundo relatos que o
correio da manhã tem conhecimento deste
quente você estava aqui uma média de dez
cães gigante adultos fome ato
simplesmente bordo foi atacado por isso
mesmo porque foi visto com comida estava
muito fácil acesso e foi atacado mas
nesta atenção não foram dez cães não não
são só dez cães foram 30 que é sério
vocês devem achar portuguesa ajudar mas
não é uma coisa assustadora é que sou
mesmo muito suspense the sun mais 30 que
a gente tudo junto em matilha é tá com
está com as pessoas andam pela rua
ladrão para os carros e os jogos
mostraram que vídeos desfalque sério é
assustador muito estudo geotécnico do
primeiro falar em estoque mas para ela
continuar correio da manhã conta que o
vereador eduardo 39 revelou que esta não
será a única medida a ser capturada e
que o processo começou agora pois o
carro não tinha capacidade
esse é outro problema é quando está
completamente cheio de carências não têm
supostamente a capacidade de alojar mais
quente então é bom em todos a tua enfim
a câmara de sintra afirmou em comunicado
que a partir desta segunda feira
começaram a decorrer trabalhos de
captura dos cães da denominava armadilha
da loura eu já tem nome da gangue com o
objetivo de salvaguardar o bem-estar ea
segurança das pessoas bens e animais não
tenhamos condições que tivemos de criar
espaços transitórios e criar
dispositivos a tarefa não era fácil ok
estou gostando tentar resolver segundo
vereador foi criado um dispositivo um
dia em metal e nessa armadilha os
cuidadores dos animais poderão colocar
água e comida para os animais nos
próximos dias como podem ver só a única
coisa que eu estou a fazer aqui é criar
uma ex-menina esse comportamento no
mundo com comida e água e os cães podem
lá e ter e comer e etc mas o problema
aqui é que os clientes continuam sem ter
um lá eles continuam sem ter um tratador
eles continuam sem ter alguém que cuide
deus que ele que vê amor então
independentemente de seus como hoje ou
amanhã depois de amanhã vão continuar a
ter formas são 30 quente no sudeste o
problema aqui não está sendo resolvida e
os parceiros tipo continuava mas que
isso vai continuar sempre só para vocês
terem noção este ataque aconteceu há um
mês atrás um mês e só agora que eu fiz
este vídeo porque eu tivesse tempo todo
a tomar conta do blog ia deixar pelo que
eu recuperasse e tetra e ainda três dias
eu fui seguida de casa porque a gente
precisava mexer a perna com um ar super
agressivo espumar da boca de mil a zero
é da globo é globo só como podem ver tem
que uma cobra morta já foi atacada pelo
pescoço e tem aqui outra capa que foi
atacada e da frida como podem ver tenham
e sangue e vamos falar agora que você já
estou a par de tudo o que está a
acontecer aqui em sintra e das notícias
e eu vou contar como foi o ataque do
bode e como é que aconteceu e como é que
hoje tanto o cinema até o fim só vou
dizer muitas coisas importantes de vôo
também é conciliar o que vocês podem
fazer por isso não acontecerá e portanto
eu até o fim então está acontecendo há
cerca de um mês
era uma da manhã se não me engano estava
forrada dormir mesmo lá em cima na sua
opinião o dante mais pessoas aqui da
agência que estavam virar alguma coisa
tipo netflix assim sei lá eu não posso
também estava tudo bem estava tudo
tranquilo mexe eu comecei a ouvir tipo
me como se fosse um ladrão armado um
atrás do monstro é como se fosse vários
monstros invadindo o jardim e para não
brincar é um consumo muito alto mas eu
pensei que fosse um curso com nilson a
negar um com o outro porque normalmente
fazem seu site com sorte pela dra
mas não foi simplesmente entrar um tipo
de 30 cães sem exagero 30 que a gente
imagine só o que é quarto noite o jardim
todo escuro e vocês verem tipo uns 30
sobras de entrar em vários negócios em
uma coisa absurda e eu estou a contar
aqui foi o clube onde me contaram a mim
porque eu não vi nada porque estava na
cama estava dormindo então quando
comecei a ouvir barulho e e as pessoas a
gritarem pois houve o be a gritar por
socorro dantas piscou e vantagens time e
quando fui lá fora já era tarde demais
quando cheguei à sala já estavam podem
chegar ainda em estudo shift santos
caído tipo admiro muito e mete muito
aflito mesmo de um fazer eu tomar chope
agora porque foi uma imagem foi muito
crítico sérgio tipo venham voz animal de
estimação é sangrar quase a morrer diz
há uma rena conselho nacional já que não
só da nossa alma e bom som vamos deixar
aqui algumas imagens como ficou depois
do veterinário como vocês podem ver a
taxa de arranhões ficou muito muito frio
ainda por cima um dos cães que conseguiu
quase atingir esta vai querer principal
que joão goulart ou sei lá e essa é uma
das vias principais tipo basta que cada
um dentro e pronto eu tenha morrido
então foi por muita sorte de ter ficado
vivo qualquer pessoa mas voltando agora
um pouco atrás quando cheguei à sala e
quando via sinte-pi tsang a primeira ea
buscar a primeira coisa que o vi logo na
hora é o bob morreu que bull e morreu
a culpa é minha portanto vou ter que
fazer alguma coisa em relação a isto e
eu a primeira coisa que eu pensei logo
instinto tipo de injustiça e de
sobrevivência celular foi de pagar uma
chave - jura por cima para que os
créditos machado em fazer tudo mas
depois pensei melhor
alguma coisa me chamou a atenção é que
os cães não tem culpa a que os clientes
estão com forma que os que estão
abandonados e que os cães atacaram o bob
por que eu faria o mesmo se fosse um cão
conforme o tipo eo zeus a nossa equipa
se ache forma e civis tipo um big mac um
sashimi de big mac a andar no jardim e
fez eu ia ficar aqui o big mac em peso
sashimi de carne eu ia atacar
é a lei da sobrevivência tão simples
quanto isso então eu depois consegui
perceber que é que os cães não têm culpa
de terem atacado bob é que os cães não
tem culpa de nada muito menos um voto e
tem culpa eu também sinto eu sinto um
pouco têm culpa porque eu devia não
fazia eu dei as condições todas que eram
precisas do bob que é um jardim ou a
andar feliz não faz casa eu estar sempre
bem em outro dentro de casa faz
companhia quase um cão nunca faltou nada
mas de qualquer maneira
ao mesmo tempo não me sinto culpado
porque por onde os cães entraram foi
pela casa onde está porque eu tenho um
triângulo tem uma cerca e este
conseguiram arrebentar a ser que
conseguiram entrar pelo pelo triângulo e
salvar tudo então nessa noite eu decidi
não colocar o bode porque muitas vezes o
comercial da noite com muita coisa e
nessa noite eu decidi não fechar o bode
dentro do triângulo porque se eu tivesse
feito o bonde estava morto
eu eu estava já no outro dia e via só o
esqueleto de web que os 15 e 16 podem
com certeza então nessa noite eu não
estava dentro do triângulo porque eu não
coloquei lá e só deixei passear e comer
relva da 'influenza' amigável e foi
precisamente nesta noite em que se
candidataram e nós conseguimos ajudar o
poder por causa disso mesmo portanto não
me sinto muito culpado por causa disto
mas ao mesmo tempo sinto que devia estar
mais de um milhão de tomar mas quanto é
o que melhor sei lá mas eu sinto também
teve ter jogado mais mas quando 93 a 91
quem já não havia nada então só tinha um
blog todos flávio cheio de sangue ea
única coisa que eu podia fazer era
ajudar depois disso imediatamente ou vai
ao plenário e outros foram em casa
ajudaram a tratar o god e correu tudo
bem e voltando um pouco atrás da minha
chave pelos cães pessoa porque o e
consegue perceber porquê que os cães
atacaram o meu blog este que eles não
estiveram aqui eles não se podem ter
chuva parece um campo aparece o campeão
eu estou ali porque são abandonados
as pessoas abandonam scut única coisa
que eles têm é egito sobrevivência de
comerem e de irem à casa seguiram aos
caixotes mas com tudo já foi o
campeonato já foi comigo eu tenho que
atacar o que é mais perto que são que
são as galinhas são as cabras são vacas
é o que for e depois disse não haver é
pessoas e cães neste momento só atacar
tudo basicamente onde quer chegar
que culpa é do ser humano portanto se tu
és uma das pessoas que estava no animal
eu quero que tu falou essas é que falece
mtg plácido bíblico uma semana
se vocês não têm que é possível ter um
animal doméstico não tem amor para dar
você não tem comida ou dinheiro ou o que
for não tem um animal de estimação
simples por acaso vocês têm condições de
ter um animal de estimação por favor
adotem primeiro antes de comprarem o que
quer que seja adotem por favor porque há
muitos animais precisam ter um lar aos
animais precisam ter amor
ainda por cima um animal doméstico eu só
precisa de duas coisas não acho que são
três comida um sítio para dormir que é
muito claro e amor e atenção só estas
coisas não exigem mais nada e fiquei sem
bateria é enfim pessoal não abandonar
animais ferir alguém fazê lo alguém
pensar em fazer por favor mandem
espírito essa pessoa chama sua atenção
porque isso não se faz o craque só de
animais se tiverem condição para tomar
conta de deus ok porque a origem deste
problema origem deste ataque ordem
destes cães andar em que as outras
não estive também serve de alerta
portanto vocês vivem aqui perto de mim
pela quinta da beloura em sintra tenho
muito cuidado na rua série
se vocês virem estes cães dentro de
algum estabelecimento fusão alguma coisa
assim pode parecer um escândalo custou
falar e pode ter cinco anos deus mundo
vai acabar mas pode acontecer vocês
nunca sabem se vão ser atacados também
descanso em 2010 portanto tenho muito
cuidado mesmo principalmente à noite o
cabrito foi atacada eu vivo cheio de
sangue ou escrita também já na perna eu
tenho para falar e por favor câmara
municipal de sintra e canil sintra façam
alguma coisa em relação às scut
continuam as buscas continuam a atacar
por favor façam alguma coisa séria por
favor é por que até agora ficaram
pessoas atacaram animais gada não
mataram ninguém só os animais 4 mas eu
quero ver o dia em que atacarem alguém
atacar uma criança sei lá e essa pessoa
morrer eu eu quero ferir o que vocês vão
fazer as relações e depois que fazem
mata-mosquitos abater escritor é isso
que vou fazer
a solução não é essa solução era amor
este carinho que eu sei que é complicado
fazer isso eu sei que o cuca não deve
taxar o cse deve ter muita coisa
complicada aí mas com certeza que dá
para fazer alguma coisa com certeza que
dá ibope só agora com novos conteúdos
sobre o ataque o do que está acontecendo
aqui
o borges estava em eu tava comprar muito
bem o time do plenário com ela tá tudo
impecável não está a recuperar muito bem
e eu também já consegue passear no
jardim normalmente porque antes não
conseguia eu ficou assim encontrar uma
como podem ver por esta imagem e por
este vídeo que eu vou passar agora eu
estava com muito medo com tanto medo que
eu ficava debaixo das mesas debaixo da
minha perna podia enfim usado por aí
está muito bem está muito feliz eu só
nos mostra isso no filme nada porque não
quer encontrar o local e com ele vêm
sugerindo bem tranqüilo e eu peço
desculpa de soltar informaram agora o
que aconteceu mexe eu quis respeitar um
pouco o processo de recuperação de um e
não quis aproveitar a mensagem e não
quis aproveitar o tipo de situação para
fazer um vídeo e para e pra estar a
ganhar viso ven
a única coisa que eu quero construir é
mesmo tempo chegar às pessoas e mostrar
que com o abandono dos animais é errado
basicamente eu quero que as pessoas
tratem melhor os animais e quer também
fazer chegar as pessoas que estavam em
que em que esta zona está mais próximo e
talvez mais seco bola e tentou mostrar
compreensão dela vou mostrar como está
portanto não percam o próximo vídeo até
pessoal
já agora deixem muito aqui mesmo e
partilhar com os nossos amigos todos
presos terem consciência disto está a
acontecer
mas nem pra toda a gente manipular os
aviões de grande porte twitter pra todo
lado por favor faça os filhos para as
pessoas podem agora vamos falar sobre
outro assunto com o passeio também
calcular esta que abalou muito boa o
pessoal aqui da casa nós ficamos muito
tempo tipo sem saber o que fazer muito
triste mesmo porque eu não sei se vocês
sentiram isso nos vídeos mais recentes
nós mas é complicado quando você estão a
viver num sítio não se sentem seguros um
desgaste mais são atacados até inclusive
agora há uma semana o fez hoje e fãs que
saltaram a vedação entraram aqui em casa
e é uma falta de respeito gigantes e e e
por isso mesmo não me sinto bem aqui é
então eu tomei a decisão de talvez
talvez 40 por cento eu irei abandonar
esta casa e tentar achar outra casa
porque tenho gravado lá né
mas amplamente eu acho que eu não vou
usufruir desta casa como como a minha
própria casa mesmo porque ser muito
sincero eu estou a jogar esta casa mas
minha intenção era comprar lá então já
primeiro mas eu não vou comprar outro
essa mesma razão que não se sente seguro
aqui então basicamente senhora se tornou
um problema que é profunda que eu vou
casar eu vou ou não ficar aqui mesmo por
isso por não se sentir bem para nós não
sentimos felizes apesar da casa serão
índice 6 e ser brutal não está então
contem com algum vídeo anunciar que
vamos sair ou talvez mas mudou de idéia
e fiquei mesmo muito provavelmente nós
não sei
então fiquem entende pessoal anf quem
diz prever quando é que nós vamos porque
eu também não sei está acontecendo muito
rápido aconteceu em um mês e sabem que
em um mês não dá pra preparar a nossa
vida assim tão bom então nós vamos ter
que o que agilizará que as coisas mas
daqui para os bodes roubaram bambara
tranquila vou para lá mas vai mudar
alguma coisa aqui então quanto muito
como a cpi só espero que vocês percebam
espero que esse percebo o porquê de eu
só estava a contar com isto agora porque
isto é que é muita emoção muita coisa e
nós também somos pessoas não é só gravar
da atow inj do animado
isso não é só assim espero que vocês
respeitem isso espero que compreendam a
minha posição o nosso lado e pronto
vamos ter novidades em breve é evódio
está super bem que o que importa a ele o
que importa mesmo certo muito feliz por
eu já sabia que só o próximo vídeo vou
mostrar o bom demonstrar compreensão
dela vão mostrar como está
se quiserem que eu faça alguma coisa
específica como embaixo quiserem que eu
faça qualquer coisa aqui nesta casa
ainda enquanto o time se quiserem mesmo
muito como tem também alguma idéia assim
é porque eu não sei se daqui pra mim eu
já estou embalar caixas e estou estou em
baladas coisas destruir embora portanto
quem tem mesmo muito pessoal já sabem
partilhem com toda a gente este vídeo
trata em banjul animais por favor
comecem os jogos ainda não começaram
e é isso fique mãe até a próxima